now let's move on to the taste of
doritos and i have to say that because
you would have no clue watching this
commercial that it is at all a doritos
commercial
[Music]
i thought he'd be alone forever thank
god he has a guy to screw in hell
what does that have to do with doritos
we have from the doritos commercial
uncle uh uncle alberto oh
can you show people they who missed the
doritos commercial again so they see the
uh yeah yeah look at him oh uncle
alberto he's on the line and uh uncle
alberto thank you for for for being here
oh thank goodness i'm very happy to be
here
and
uh he's uh proud
uh on halloween yeah
dia de la muerte and i like doritos
uh
thank you oh okay so uncle alberto let
me ask you um uh doritos obviously uh
your skeleton how did you how did you uh
how did you die
oh the eastern story east event i was uh
see any fishing boat
you know
the charm you're a fishing charter yeah
fishing jury yeah yeah i know
yeah i know a fishing charter yes and uh
we had a problem with the ball no
so okay so you died in a he i guess you
died in a fishing accident
oh no that was just a the story uh uh
nothing
he's he's eight oh wow makes sense i
gained that coming yeah by the way the
doritos thing to be really clear you
know that you have the uh the the
grandmother he's a miracle i thought you
were going to be really you think that a
90 year old grandmother from mexico who
who has a rosary is going to be happy
that her dead son is gay she would have
used some cheeseburgers do you think
she's showing up and leaving doritos an
astroglide at that headstone
for crying out like what year old
mexican grandmothers are based yeah well
you know what okay uh alberto was your
grandmother was she really proud of you
oh no no no she was uh no she in the
commercial she was proud of uh they
ended uh hundreds
out of context out of context is that
what it was so what do you mean she cuz
she said she was a miracle she was proud
of you yeah no the con they aired it
together she was saying she was proud
he's a miracle her empanadas came out
perfect
but for me and mario
she feels great shane okay
yeah you and well you and you and the
bisexual superman no no no okay good
i've noticed
we can be together in the extra life you
know i i'm kind of busy saving oh come
on don't be such a [ __ ] boy eternity is
not a long time please find a phone
booth and we can change together i'm not
i'm not superman that's a good thing
you're able to give me an erection in a
single bone i i look look i i just
stopped all right this is enough of that
okay that's a split screen that gives
children nightmares oh yes chris cuomo
and don lemon
i don't know which is worse that or then
the split screen that follows with
anderson cooper and wolf blitzer wolf oh
that is terrible yes or then on the
weekend you can get sanjay gupta or dr
fariza and brian stelter and jake it
just keeps going down yeah it's weird
because anderson cooper and
wolf blitzer does look like he
transformed into him right yeah a little
bit like that's the gay werewolf
celebrity jeopardy just sucked his soul
out along with all his points lowest
score ever on celebrity jeopardy well
flitz was like negative 6 000.
so don limon money wolf
you went into celebrity jeopardy and you
cost the charity money you get
nothing there's some kid with pro jiri
on his last breath going damn you wolf
right after that rebecca's like i don't
know what i just saw but my side hurts
[Laughter]
but i'll beat it now i don't know if i
looked at the i look at the bottom tax
increases and it's anybody making over
400 000 that's crazy that's not rich
that's upper middle class i'm like you
didn't know this until you got on air
it's not because you're a woman it's
because you're stupid hold on that's
upper middle class yeah well she's just
pretty rich which is pretty rich but she
was saying she thought it was you know
the one percent making millions she
realizes it's going to affect her i was
looking it's any joint household making
over four hundred thousand this is we
need to know these people are not rich
like really how much so do you make
their job well yeah it's just funny
because yeah whoopi goldberg doesn't
think she's rich
i make 10 million dollars and let me
tell you that is not rich the point is
she didn't know until she went on air
yeah exactly these people are
journalists informed oh
that's not a bad whoopi by the way no
that's pretty good whoopee ah yeah i
have to talk about things i don't know
about it's crazy it's it's crazy child
my dog actually looks like whoopi
goldberg in the 80s so does predator
yeah
that's true true well
hold on i have to go hunt with heat
seeking technology
so he's just camouflaging in a tree
wants some candy and if the election
were held today
he would win and i think that the black
democrats they're now the moderate wing
of the party again get rid of the black
lives matter terrorist organization i'm
talking about the average you know black
american in detroit right now
what do you think what do you think
they're doing for pride month they don't
even have a place to file this [ __ ]
beating up their son
i mean
you know i did for pride man
i've been ashamed
[Laughter]
well well gil hill was the first like
even known uh you know
police chief in detroit he was in uh
hill cop yeah he was the you know the
guy who swears at axel the whole time
crazy was the
police chief of detroit yeah so they
were like oh we were gonna get an actor
but this guy's a way bigger piece of
[ __ ]
it was amazing kind of like frank rizzo
from philly yeah exactly effectively but
the difference was detroit you know you
spent a lot of time in new york or
boston is uh if you want to hide a body
in detroit you put it in grand central
state yeah
or if it's that's the place no one
checks remember they would have to there
were a few years at grand central
station in grand central station they
were just clearing out homeless bodies
from the elevator shaft it was just
almost dead oh both dead almost right
above jordan's steakhouse
boy what's that uh what are those rib
eyes
yeah and there you always have to hear
some hipster in a skateboard say it's
coming back it's gotta be that cream
broccoli
homeless guys carcasses
the elephant man rotting on floor sick
yeah
somebody shot the door of the men's room
i felt a lot of guns
just enjoying an 85 dollar steak
surrounded by dead bodies oh that that
must be the turf it's the midwest yeah
it probably had to be shipped in
peta
recently released a clip and if you have
children they shouldn't watch this after
all that nice baby talk and they're
gonna go to degenerates at peta
who would have thought that vegans would
be degenerates
weird
we're surprised
here's their ad promoting veganism
because of course
people listening on audio it's
they're fondling fruit and
vegetables in a sexual manner
claiming that fruits and vegetables
enhance your sex life a very specific
thing that men can't find yes
not that one
is that lizzo it's almost over
[Music]
peter if you think that's bad wait till
we go to mug club later it gets worse it
gets so much worse that's so terrible
yeah what do you
i i was just laughing i was just
envisioning a hole just drilled in a
melon
anybody seen that video that's the male
audience on that one
i speak for peta jason biggs oh they had
alicia silverstone uh naked in times
square as one of their ads i'm sorry
what yeah
look no i agreed with it that one dave
went vegan for a week after and then
there was an amber alert on all our
phones for alicia silverstone
and i looked up and i was like yeah i
think i'll cut out red meat for a while
yeah but yeah that makes some sense here
this just makes me want to just actually
just eat a cow raw yeah in front of
someone who loves it yeah just for spike
no no they hate meat meat is disgusting
right that's absolutely that's why your
your vegan burgers in no way try to
recreate exactly what was delicious in
the first place it's an impossible
burger yeah because it's impossible to
match the taste with crappy plants yes
it is
and it's a bunch of processed crap
anyway
tell us more about mma and the
heterosexuality of it yeah oh i
apologize
yes it's not like it's not lately
homosexual it's blatantly completely
yeah that's true you're not i'm not
hiding you yeah north south is what
position again stephen yeah north south
is head and crotch
we call that 69 in the dayton game yeah
that's what they call it yeah well i
should tell you about turtle
so
that's just a tuesday night in the
bootage family yeah oh well yeah
well
not so much lower not so much anymore
it's hard when you're breastfeeding so
you gotta keep it you gotta spice it up
he's drinking a lot of milk trying to
make milk
not working
he's just mixing hops in uh similac
[Music]
just grow up save
skeletons and cuffs men can have milk
ducks yeah they can yeah there was a
rumor that uh i won't you know it's i
mean that's a that's a medical condition
used to uh lactate produce when he was
aroused really yes i don't know
i bet it's true it's got to be true
listen
when i lactate
bad things happen
[Laughter]
high protein levels
i have registered lethal weapon hands
yes why i have to be very careful when i
eat in public i'm also not allowed to
carry these hands into an establishment
that makes more than 50
of the profit off alcohol
because it's like i'm carrying do you
see what i'm saying
i have a great ponytail and i can feed
your baby with my ninja tits
[Laughter]
what a worthless
you and i watched what was it
what was that which was it dmx it was
dmx it was written by a four-year-old
yeah we left so the greatest line ever
they go into like
it's like 10 minutes of them looking
over security camera footage right and
steven's sorry we're going to get to
kyle rittenhouse in a little bit this is
totally relevant yeah was it is it exit
wounds with dmx
yes i don't know what we were thinking
yeah but i think we ordered halal guys
and watched exit wounds what and
there's i'll set it up
are you serious all the other characters
in the film are going over security
camera footage it was like a bank oh
yeah they're looking at like the kind of
watch he has what time it was like yeah
being very detailed they're like oh he
has this kind of watch well if that's a
fake he only could have picked it up you
know 23rd and 4th or whatever and
they're going through all these details
on the security camera footage to try
and identify the thief and after about
five minutes steven seagal speaks up
hand to god
he's black
[Laughter]
good call steven dmx it's like we just
both laugh for 10 minutes cause like
everybody in the room is going to go
yeah yeah thanks
dude he's acting like he figured out
he's black oh my god stephen why don't
you go teach us how to run
why don't you ask usain bolt i taught
him everything he knew oh should you i'm
going to say wear a vest with no shirt
under it and play a little guitar do you
guys mind oh and i'm going to cut two
holes in the vest just because uh it
gets heavy yes so i'm gonna feed your
baby without my nipple
ninja ninja what if he was called by the
butt giggs as a midwife
he probably was
you check that baby
i'll deliver them your
i've delivered thousands of babies i've
delivered thousands of babies and killed
many chickens
given a c-section just by going like
this oh my god yes i look at him and
he's circumcised
why are you looking at baby penis no i
don't you do it's you yeah
i mean it's a procedure
you start
burning his computer
i said the wrong thing he's pouring
bleach on top that's not oxygen powder
it doesn't work this is fuzzy
he's calling the customer service hilary
hello guy with beard from oxiclean
there's still kitty born on my imac and
i've bleached it twice
i need a sham wow
i've been scouting circumcisions again
all right welcome
while you're there get me jack lalanne
i could use a juicer so uh i have to put
on a little few put on a few pounds
so okay oh my gosh what is this guy what
is this i want to hear what they have to
say can we it's like it's like it's a
real glass like spazzer it's like the
delorean broke gay harry potter
into
doing their job
prosecuting people who break the law
it's not a circus it's not a show you're
not a circus you're just basically okay
[Laughter]
is that a furry helmet over there on the
couch oh my gosh
[Laughter]
he's got to be on a different zoom in a
minute
just because after the prosecution's
statement van jones and navarro just
dropped out like who can we get uh pink
glasses guy oh my god you mean the one
who looks like bruce valance screwed an
alcoholic 50 year old harry potter yeah
isn't he a furry we'll ask him to get it
out of the frame it's in the frame
there's no time we don't have time
he doesn't have the bow tie that goes
does he
i'll just do it as long as i can wear my
most fun glasses
[Laughter]
wait you mean the glasses with the lines
that you can't see out of no i didn't
say my second most fun classes
oh you mean the ones with the big stars
like elton john those are third
we've been through this
you know you said that to hurt me yeah
we now go to elton john if he didn't
make it
ugh he comes within an inch of that
skateboard hitting him in the head i
he's on tv
that's unbelievable and then he defends
himself again there's no way for them to
make this case oh i'm wearing my
masturbation glasses
oops oh
these are the tube in addition
i thought those i thought those were
your flashing glasses now these are my
masturbation glasses the flashing
glasses are green what is the bust he
says over there
really i'm sorry i was just filming it's
already
down like i just this is court tv and
people wonder look look look you wonder
why people mistrust institutions it's
like once upon a time in the era of
walter cronkite americans trusted their
media and i don't know why well [ __ ]
okay all right doctors well i guess i
catch fake memes on facebook aren't that
bad
someone
someone give me my ruth better ginsburg
no no no statue shoulder ruth gator
vader ginsberg left shoulder fun time
later ferry uh let's take down the
statues of the angel kids urinating
there's already too much talk of
pedophiles in this case
but we can take those down those are a
landmark i'll just say they were uh
we'll just say they were in the
confederacy what the hell is the
difference what is that statue
look right over his head is that like is
that what is that a drawing of i don't
know
i want to see a cartoon i want to take a
whole episode to go through this guy's
office somebody screen grab this we're
going through piece by piece oh what is
that like what is it behind them oh my
gosh it it looks like a cat with plus
and minus i i felt that the glasses
would distract from my disgusting i'm
never just out of a sheer morbid
curiosity wanted to be the magic mirror
on the wall prepared for this hit
mirror mirror on the wall stop throwing
up
okay
[Laughter]
he's just actually taunting the news
because he's wearing evidence we don't
know about yet
boy these glasses sure do easily get
picked up on those fbi plane camps
and as you can see with the heat map
right behind this is awful i gotta tell
you look this is this is going to be the
narrative i guarantee you're somebody
i should probably step out i'm gonna be
laughing
i have to go to the bathroom
can we order a pair of those i don't
even have lenses wait
[Laughter]
i feel like under this guy's
oh this guy is definitely good
baby side by side
i'm gonna die the other baby was better
i tell you what if someone finds that
listing on a child like a child website
like i don't know gymboree or gap baby i
swear i'm gonna die this is amazing i'm
gonna die
all i ask is that you do not look under
my crawl space for tiny
[Laughter]
stop
skeletons
oh my god oh my god he buys baby gloves
his house is so drafty what oh why don't
you put insulation between these walls
and waste all that space
boy you got a septic leak or something
no leave i've seen sicario
too
just the funny thing is that going from
him to kyle rittenhouse it just makes
one of them look legitimate if he had a
pinwheel
oh it's like a gay cheshire cat
thank you
thank you for visiting wonderland
just puts on his tail and stands on top
of a cabinet like a clock
yes now if you'll excuse me i just puts
on cat ears and starts removing his
shirt
i've got to go to work at disneyland
he's got maggie's just buttering his
chest oh my god oh we stopped i'm sorry
i thought i was hungry i'm sorry i if i
stood up accidentally screen shares his
next day ordering nipple wax
it's for surfing
they don't make rash cards for people my
not size shape yes i'm waiting on dave
because he's going to the bathroom but
he has a prostate the size of a
basketball
that's a big prostate is the guy still
always right that's not a compliment
there he is prostate this oh never mind
that's the opposite oh no no it's the
clown oh my gosh it's
don't look when you come in don't look
you can't look at it he's gonna just die
laughing
but then when you heard more that was
making like an earnest face now like
he's disappointed imagine if that was
your father and he found out that you
know you broke curfew yeah and he's like
i'm disappointed in you son
you know the
my dad you know the crowder name used to
mean something
[Laughter]
what's the guy with the glasses and
harry potter that picks up harry and
tries to save him and he's licking his
lips all the time oh maybe he only is
one he has a monocle they're right
anyway there's one person in harry
potter
harry potter no no no no not
not him he doesn't have glasses it's one
of the wild it's just a one wild thing
yeah never mind let me kind of looks
maybe this guy is just such
a brain brilliant commentary he's like
even saying that we've all we've
wrongfully pre-judged let's hear what he
has to say take this apart each set is
going to focus
individuals
that justify their position so for kyle
rittenhouse he's going to be able to
provide evidence that notice he's going
to be trying to cut off his triple chin
he had been told that they were writers
that he was there with law enforcement
protecting a community and he's going to
have all that right it's like an adam
sandler character
he's going to testify
i play jack and jill and then i go down
to burn down the fire balloon
they're burning the gas
[Music]
all right dave get to your seat mister
just don't look at the guy on the screen
mr piss and razor blades no don't look
[Laughter]
oh party glasses mr written house yeah
it's our ex girl it's our expert [ __ ]
consultant yeah chief
i like mrs potato head glasses
what question did you have
i'm that next did you prefer mrs pac-man
to mr pac-man because she was less
threatening uh i prefer uh neither
pac-man because i don't see gender ah
what i do see your point is you yeah my
pants that's when you start playing
pitfalls
i'm going to wear these or worms
oh do we know when they're coming nope
i'm going to do it all right okay so now
look we are going to because i can't do
it with you like that
and by the way
they're still not as silly look at me
they're still not as silly as the guy
was actually wearing look at him he's
the piece of [ __ ]
why would you go to him
you could have anyone on earth yes look
how excited he is at the edge of his
seat fort tv ladies and gentlemen
by the way uh not a chance that facebook
checks that facebook checks their
facebook lives sorry meta live stream as
a non-authoritative
so we're going to have uh our employees
here yeah safety first safety first yes
yes
guys
safety first you're going to do uh hey i
i don't you have a pair of glasses no no
i have glasses you're fine these aren't
bullets by the way you do lick these i
can't even see through them
they're special glasses i licked all the
glasses you don't want to know what was
on there before leave them in a room
with rosenbaum and little tumblers oh
geez okay i left him in a sauna yeah all
right so beltbar.com and use what's the
promo code there built.com use crowder15
for 15 off your next order built.com
sorry builtbar.com is hardcore
pornography yeah don't don't put that
build.com and use the promo code crowder
to get a discount code how does that
feel in your mouth
[Music]
[Laughter]
listen built bartender they pay for that
i think i'm ready to go uh go back in
the streets yeah okay all right
go take it to the streets i like to
watch him chew
[Laughter]
all right there's a mystery flavor on
the front page no what what is that what
that's not rosenbaume
is it shake of arrow it's injected it's
something i came up with yes exactly yes
it's bruce valanche ball hair oh
all right seriously i look i appreciate
but you're taking your life in your
hands you order why fox food
mystery box food
well built bar you can trust they're
going to give you something i i know i
still wouldn't no okay i feel like
you're signing all all legal liability
there if you're like i'm like sure yeah
yeah yeah one of the mixed boxes better
than that right mystery all right so is
the defense
what are they doing right now a trip to
the pharmacy won't cost as much anymore
for essential items like tampons and
pads after governor whitmer signed a
bipartisan bill ending the so-called
tampon tax i never dreamed number one
we'd get it done
number two would take this long to get
it done from eddie murphy's raw i'd be
the one who gets to sign this bill into
one of michael jackson
this is a step toward empowering and
supporting women in this economy and and
menstruating michiganders
well
as you know i am stretching and i spent
a lot of money on champions yes i gotta
tell you it is
quite a bundle sometimes i just use a
turkey leg from a renaissance yeah
honestly that's absolutely true
sometimes you do a turkey leg and now
you got always pads with uh with the
wings and you know optional heated uh
heated seats for crying out loud back i
would just you know i just tie a rabbit
skin with some cinnamon yeah that's what
i would do i just i'm it's very very
broken in there you know but yeah i
needed a good i'd like
a good carpet square but you know what
that's back then
you didn't see
periods from guys so everything the
rules are changing all around you know
rabbit skins guys guys menstruating too
you know you gotta get with the times
yeah i asked my doctor i said my
husband's uh penis is menstruating yeah
and he says that's not what that is
oh and i i said are you sure and she
said yeah yeah yeah she said she said
well maybe if you stop whacking it with
a mallet
[Laughter]
stop hurting yourself oh man
yeah
your penis shouldn't bleed let's no
you're going to be honest they have
actually intimidated the governor of
michigan enough to say menstruating
michiganders people who menstruate now
what's the problem with that when they
try to tell it was the name of my
football team right yes you know my dad
has a my dad has a [ __ ] up sense of
humor i uh i was uh in the i was in uh
the kitchen making myself an omelet i
hear the old man laughing his head off
and in the other room i have no idea
what's going on
and and i don't just and i i walk in
lady dies funeral
he goes and he wasn't just like like
that deep belly laughs like robert de
niro in cape fear
just clapping with the cigars the cigar
i know which cigar it was too
but uh yeah i just recently was like you
know but the was it nick napoli says you
know it's not that the lady died but
apparently one of the horses took a [ __ ]
right when they were carrying the casket
you understand the pomp and circumstance
of this of this absolutely beautiful
princess uh with her nose and death six
inches away being [ __ ] on by a palomino
you're missing the point
um did we find it the cape fear i think
so all right this is one so this is just
and then we'll go to chat but this is
one of those performances she's like in
her i think she was in her 20s when she
did it she's playing a 14 year old oh
geez and it's really and just so you
know it's very unsettling but i i don't
i don't think there's any i don't know
how old she is in it because i know on
christmas vacation she was still a
teenager which was 89 and this was a
little bit when she filmed it she was a
teenager christmas vacation she was yeah
i don't know which one is she and chris
i don't know she's the oldest sister
yeah should i offer me a little fungus
she's audrey oh okay yeah yeah yeah all
right and then she's in you know strange
days natural born killers yeah strange
days she rollerblades topless enjoy
dave what promoting that i'm not going
to pretend i don't like heart stop
looking i didn't like the film
i didn't name it like i said anything
about the film no i was it was a weird
score the strange days yeah strange days
they shouldn't have had randy
where she's writing topless strange
things are happening to me
i hate ain't no doubt about it
give me another
oscar i'm just gonna play three chords
you got a friend and move the uh oscars
you got a friend in my contract he just
says what happens in the story yeah it's
the worst look buzz lighty is going down
the stairs
he doesn't like them but they learn to
trust each other
he's the father of the bride and the
bride's getting nervous but he fixes the
situation that day and
try and be empathetic because there's a
lot of emotions that go all wedding day
and tom hanks got a cough that won't go
away and downtown washington says bye
cause he's gay
philadelphia dave's there this weekend
yeah let me hear you say it philadelphia
opening with aids this weekend closed
casket coughing cause they weren't sure
how it spread that's what happened after
they found the lawyer dead
brandy
let me tell you about dallas buyers
crossing the border to order non-fouchy
pills that work
jared leto's not even from dallas no
from fort worth which is technically a
sister city okay the woman are you
taking audience requests uh do
schindler's list okay
those jews are getting skinny man
i tell you what somebody get those jews
from food there's one thing that they're
not loving and that is that long line
for the oven
i'm talking about shimla's lips how can
i get on it
he's like he's like
that would be all
[Music]
but now he's dead
i tell you what's not great schindler
was 6 million late
now
transformers go them to me buy another
jupiter jared liked this shitty movie
how did i become the story which one
that's a true transformer
yeah actually he did he did do
transformers
doing really well and oh mark wahlberg
didn't know that
[Laughter]
so that's the wrong movie
he's just stealing lines in jurassic
park hold on to your butt buddy
just vomiting on the keyboard because
you're so drunk and all he eats is candy
no one's got a friend in me
all right no one else is we still gotta
play that clip oh yeah yeah
i don't know if that's nothing like
randy newman but he's that dave just i i
i i thought i liked randy newman as a
kid yeah yeah right and then i
grew up and i was like this is
25 yeah sure people got no reason to
live no reason to live that's the only
reason to live you randy knew me
what is it with the glasses oh my gosh
look it's like that again
who is that glasses every time right now
she looks like she's the teacher in
harry potter who you would think was the
bad person but then was a good person
and then turned out was a bad thing she
looks like she looks like what sally
field had to take off before she banged
the principal yeah before she got
osteoporosis
they love me they really crack
the phone stopped ringing bone density i
hurt
there's not enough calcium on the earth
to make me somewhat doable again hello
caa hello all right let's go i got
caught sorted not really
she was cute she was cute she was cute
so she she was actually 18 uh
the other actress we were talking about
when the movie came out
yeah she probably filmed it when she was
like 17. yeah she played like a 13 year
old or 14 year old or something like
that she played a very naive she played
it very well yeah so this is the scene
where robert de niro is approaching nick
nolte's daughter at school kind of
trying to seduce her and she doesn't
really
she doesn't have a great relationship
but let's go back to when they were
telling us that the lockdowns would work
and why they would work
thereby helping to protect the
vulnerable
and sparing many families the pain
already felt by those who have lost
loved ones by the way you keep the pearl
necklace i've ever worn by the way you
can't see but hersheiner is a big black
guy from chip and dale's oh wow
it's i prefer it this way he doesn't
even use his hands of course we don't
let him change the royal gene pool
i wave like this and not all you
commoners have a hundred thousand square
foot home to stay in like i do at
buckingham palace and you can't all say
that your your father is in fact your
uncle really oh yes my my nephew's
dating or what what wow oh no oh
the what's the proper pejorative i'm
supposed to use these days
we're supposed to all be cousins
could we have some paparazzi follow her
24 7 just to especially particularly
while she's driving an expressway maybe
in a tunnel
love
oh very fast
so here's no seat belts in the limousine
no secrets not in a rule
we mustn't argue with tradition
those wills need to have no tread
yes also you'll you'll find your booster
seats there yeah
i'm an adult
it's tradition
pomp and circumstance you know india 75
million people driven into poverty what
and in india that's really poor well
that's yeah that's going from very very
differently poverty i mean they go from
pooping in the streets to pooping in uh
uh
less nice streets yes yes dirtier poop
covered
my legs i wish we had a bunch of things
to eat there's a cow right there no
no that we worship don't be crazy
look at dave being crazy he's saying eat
cow
watch me twist my penis around this rod
like a pretzel and the penis yogi
by the way if you don't know that that's
an actual thing that's impressive that's
an actual thing
it's where they roll their balls around
them
like a lampshade that is not impressive
i know it's impressive no i think it's
no it's 75 you can't do it can you
millionaire i don't care i didn't used
to have to do this but after coving we
all had to find a way to put chutney on
the table
what's the point look at that
look he's like a lampshade with my
testicles okay look at that
why do they do that that's my boy i
don't know i don't care if you're
impressed i don't know i have no idea
but there's some dumb broad who's on our
eat pray love journey who decides to go
up he's like oh my god i really found
myself you know what you can find my
gland's penis tied around this bow and
arrow look i shoot and my glen's penis
arrow comes back to me
oh
food i was brutally raped on a train and
a bus
part of my journey i went to india and
it's super spiritual these people by the
way i say this because i feel incredibly
empathetic to the people of india my
brother went to india on a mission trip
i think you've been to india no no uh
cambodia okay sorry but my brother went
i thought he stopped through india that
must have been one of my brother's
friends but uh he went through india and
uh he was like look at this
when people talk about the chasm of the
middle class oh it's it's it's
unbelievable the poverty is unreal but
people here love to say oh it's so
spiritual yeah right like oh my gosh i'm
on my spiritual journey yes i hope that
spiritual journey is going very well for
you um okay here's something that in our
holy texts is very important custom and
that is you will notice i brought a very
large suitcase you're going to check
your bag i am going to yogi myself into
this bag
[Laughter]
and you can eat pray love me all the way
through custom
how about india india doesn't do a good
job with this either guys well india yes
they don't do a good job of anything in
india well india's i don't want to
vilify an entire nation program maybe
it's a horrible place programming what
do you mean programming programmers are
you kidding me yeah oh i thought you
were on the television program
you're seeing bollywood films it's all
the same you ever listened to their top
40 who wants to be radio programming
like billionaire number one i like
number two this week hi
hi well just number three
my first girlfriend was indians oh
did you have the accent no no i wouldn't
have talked to her oh
she was an american indian but not an
american native no no no she was
american indian she was american but
happened to be of indian heritage and
you communicated through the language of
love yes you gotta get out of your head
our bodies
to one another i used to call her sticky
dot
okay
unfortunately dave is not here today
because he came down with the uh the big
bird flu so we actually have uh in his
place greta thundberg's uh older sister
brother uh how are you
i'm fine
okay ahoy and what are you are you
greta's older brother older sister yes
okay
i i i was supposed to be the first
anti-climate change
bloomberg but then gretchen came along
she began to develop early and caught
everyone's attention and i was left
to be nothing oh no and you were in the
attic and mother never came for you that
mother never comes for me she never
calls oh those stewnbergs in the attic
all my family members are very
attractive except for me yeah wow
well i guess it's a relative term i've
seen your parents right
yes they're very doable mm-hmm
okay that was my catchphrase yes i get
it i understand the double dare you
added she had a little i added a double
added a little bit of zest yeah
he trimmed it i dare you to stop ruining
the planet even great another brave well
you know what challenge not accepted by
now the new prediction is by 2035 60 of
our meat will have to be lab grown
hasn't the colonel been doing that for
years
he's like you are my eyeless babies
you're born without feathers what are
the secret herbs and spices crickets
what i do to them is the spice oh
what their pain they can't speak
their screams are the extra spice doctor
slash four star general rachel levine
admiral that's it oh i thought it was a
general four-star admiral admiral oh
all playtime
it really is
that's a half star for each bowl
yeah or two stars
oh
and that's a thing if uh he's a really
bad female general she'll just get uh
two balls yeah they just come in here
they rip his balls off
you're big you're finished here you've
brought shame to your
yeah they take away the stars and add
the balls back
you're a guy again
they start stitching in scrotum hair
into the side of their shoulders go feed
your baby
everything's upsy downsy what a
stupid dr seuss world religion yeah is
it okay to call him a [ __ ]
i don't know well yeah you get
everything out there on the rules let's
ask gene charlotte on cnn
he looks like he should be taken
seriously who is this guy
i do experiments in my garage on
neighborhood kids
oh no it's in texas damn it the guy
looks like i still have refrigerators
that you can't open from the inside
i own an ice cream parlor i also killed
my family yes
but i jerk a mean soda
so does the name yeah soda by the way is
this young man
if you were first name soda last name
pop
if you were a bow tie and you're not
bill nye you can just straight up after
yourself it's why i still look like bill
[Laughter]
yeah pretty much bow tie done if you
come in in a bow tie to give me any
diagnosis i'm getting a second opinion
yeah
the front is that right here in civic
park
no sorry that's my mistake um
you're walking north on sheridan he
makes painful gilbert godfrey faces yeah
no i was at car shores four
that's when the pedophile trying to [ __ ]
me
you saw the hd he was getting close
how did you know he was a pedophile
there you go him with the fire
extinguisher how do you know he was a
pedophile mr written house well
something i figured what a bald man with
a mental hospital plastic bag is walking
down an alleyway with a raging erection
he's not collecting for the red cross
[Laughter]
bob reese predicted her rice i don't
care predicted that lower manhattan
would be completely underwater by 2018.
uh well here's the thing actually the
truth doesn't happen no no the truth is
it actually has
yeah just not for the reasons they
thought yeah so you know
[Laughter]
i don't know if that's in the archive uh
new york city will be awash in hobo piss
that was the day after tomorrow jake
gyllenhaal we have to get the library
why hobo piss
in any consolation it's in much worse
shape it's true it might be might be
being underwater would be a great thing
for lower manhattan kind of
[Applause]
you can shove your climate crisis
you know i agree i couldn't have said it
better i don't know why she's singing
songs though
i don't know
could be a correlation i have a guess
but i'm not allowed to say it she's
gonna do itsy bitsy spider next yeah
yeah i have no idea
climate change went up the people spout
down came acid rain and kill all the
people out
oh so sad i just lost your say down came
the hobo piss and washed the new york
city out
dicaprio
that's honestly how you know your city
sucks when hobo piss is cleansing i live
there there's nothing shocking about
that photo no no that's just where their
bathroom is hobo's pissing in your
streets in manhattan is basically an
herbal essences commercial first yeah
the real problem is camera phones uh in
general because that would have been
taken care of by a simple nudge of a cab
like in the good old days that's the
problem now hey bird scooters don't have
enough velocity exactly
because really yeah well it's unless
it's a hobo kid but you know we can take
them out anymore well no yeah you're
right it could be a hobo kid i don't
need a scooter for that singing about
pickpocketing it's a good push kick you
could come on getting a hobo kid yeah
got to pick a pocket or two
we've got a piss in a street or two
extra extra read all about hey this is
yesterday's doom paper we already have
your 20. get him
all right fade him to death in the
street yeah ah listen sir i'm just uh
i'm just homeless pickpocket trying to
sell me papers you just say you were a
pickpocket boy i said paper salesman
today i pushed a dandy man in front of
the subway train yeah but it was his
fault he was pissing on the third round
he was
less carbon when i when i went to push
him away i gave myself a shock
ronald fell in oh yeah could have been
an old lady on her porch yeah watching
the fire from afar drinking the mike's
hard lemonade yeah then she just got hit
with a stray nine millimeter
we're gonna have a beer like it's the
end of a war movie yeah he's gonna
they're gonna take a dead pedophile with
a rag over his head
all right he said they're having
technical difficulties uh and uh
twenty-five what is a different thing
they're about to go to lunch it's a dead
pedophile with a rag it's like hey
hey hey don't you quit on me don't you
quit on me you'll be raping kids before
you know it look at this look at this
we're gonna be in the sunset making a
boat with kids in the hall
the whole time he's uh
he's naming uh different different
positions like bubba and forrest gump
so they're pausing for i think a
45-minute break there can be a reverse
cow minor
look here's a picture of my cousin look
at it there's uh there's 69 when they're
six and nine
toilets for the toothbrush it's all
definitely terrible stuff
yes i do say if i put on the wig i
believe the lights will be more
attracted to it than my scalp yes yes i
did not no no now hold still will i well
i place these leeches on your scrotum to
suck out the demons
yes absolutely what's that foul's
oh it's me yes i forgot to take my
annual bath and i'm royalty you'll see
i can only imagine what the peasants
smell like where we'll have them burned
no idea
they're crying out loud oh yeah i
learned very little in school but i do
did learn
sometimes they'd have mice in them yeah
wait what yeah they would have mice in
those wigs it'd be like in that scene in
home alone too when they're in the park
and that one flies out of the coat
they'd be sitting there like all right i
hereby
why do you think there's so many mice
fables yeah because back then all they
had was lice and mice yep and it wasn't
nice cut off their tail with a carving
knife which seems like something you
shouldn't read to children just a gross
people with crotch rot they cut off with
a carving knife the three blind mice and
they're so three blind mice
and they're curious about why they
almost all died from a plague really
yeah i mean it's the cats kill the cats
oh yes yes it's all the cats use here
we'll all have to use one area for the
bathroom and leave it there forever yes
it doesn't does appear that the reason
my crotch is oozing green pustules is i
believe it's the feline fault yes uh and
no it's the sins we must beat the sins
out of each other yes beat the sins
that's what they that's what happened
with all of it they started killing the
cats because one guy didn't want to
admit his venereal disease
it's the catch
it's the cat who came over here from gin
alley you see they carry ghosts and
demons ah what's that word your
prostitute i would never if you can't
what does that work never i do say that
tabby looks at me cross i do believe
that he's fidgeting while i sleep you
know i don't know how it happened i wore
a scumbag
i did
you know as well i wrapped my penis my
john thomas and rabbit skins as well as
the next chap thank god that city burned
otherwise they would never have ended
the plague yeah it's true which city are
we talking about england well it's not a
city well i'm sorry not england london
england
the rats the rats were the problem they
killed the thing that naturally would go
after the rats cats yeah and then they
didn't know it's like you guys did it to
yourself you have any millions of people
died you morons that's true that's why
we hey you hey you you there you're
there cat stop stop pestering that rat
they they they they clean up diseases
you you create them
you stop that we have to get rid of the
cats if we don't get rid of the cats
we'll have no more rats what will we do
with our hygiene with no rats oh be
gross that would be like saying that we
would we will be without our unwashed
wool wigs i've trained this one to push
a ball there's almost no blood in my
urine today that's a first yeah
it was also used to hide syphilis
symptoms oh
sores on the heads yeah oh gosh
syphilis down there hold on did they
have like a take a hat leave a hat
because i don't want to get it after the
bloody scalp if we don't do a wig
commercial now i'm gonna be mad do you
need to cover your syphilis scars it
also didn't help
to stop preventing the spread of
syphilis that we played musical wigs
yeah no doctor my syphilis sores are
everywhere have you considered a
powdered wig yes yes absolutely
considered a powdered wig here i have
one that's just perfect it's been out in
the rain for four weeks yeah it's good
oh mo look at the rats they're right now
go fish in the pool while your brain
rots away
it's a sign of upper society you know oh
my gosh
hail skin and sibling souls that's how
they know that you're royalty
you're the two guys you're like all
right everybody has to wear wigs and you
have to powder your faces yeah otherwise
we'll look like idiots
think about they disciplined like but
father do i have to have sex with my
sister yes yes you must or you don't get
your blood pudding you know yes oh jeez
we must
we were such idiots how did we survive
ridiculous there's no way we'll be so
inbred that royalty will look inbred
till the end of time yeah currently to
this day yes to this day
i don't know if performing coitus on
your first cousin is beneficial you know
your teeth will grow sideways oh that's
just an old second wives tale not true
just current people smiling from britain
with jack diana's attractive let's take
out the seat belts yes
kill her run the car faster
now you see we must get rid of diana to
make room for that bulldog camilla yeah
she fits in nicely what is the family
well camilla's more look sometimes you
choose over beauty the most reliable and
camilla wears a dinner bell we can hear
where she goes she is at a track yes
i mean if prince charles is not the
poster boy for being inbred
yeah he has those weird inbred teeth
right they're just like every time i
like hanging him i want to spin him
around like the elephant man
he's going to be king for like five
minutes after waiting 50 years yes
the the queen's gonna die it's gonna be
sad and then he's gonna be like all
right i'm finally
i just can't wait to be dead [ __ ] oh
bother
guys blood is the color of cookie
monster
and it's the same viscosity
actually how am i uh i caught and i just
seemed to uh i seem to hemorrhage felt
this is odd where's mother who's been
the same age and look of 95 for the last
40 years yes yes she's sort of like a 95
year old diane lane you know she always
looked like an attractive fortitude even
when she was 20 but then she was an
attractive 40 year old even when she was
55 only 90.
[Laughter]
we call it the ashley judd effect she
waves like a [ __ ]
well that's just because you understand
her father was also her brother so oh
joints don't work quite like that
why do i wave like this oh because
you're your parents horrible
uncle slash father
that's why she wears a powdered wig
[Laughter]
she takes it off she just looks like
freddy krueger
no don't worry that's just syphilis
that is not too far from the pictures
they've been sending me i'm not going to
show these on the show
they look like freddy krueger
who the control room is sending me
pictures of syphilis it looks like
pretty good let me see
one let me this will you know what i bet
it's gonna look like freddy's nightmare
you know that's the sixth one where you
can go back yeah oh no more he looks
more it's uh the new nightmare yeah that
one was actually better than the other
sequels but i burn him again oh this is
bad no okay tell me when you want me to
take it off all right
[Applause]
why would you not just kill yourself
hold on hey look i have these holes in
my head oh no no no right there
in my hand quick get the rats get the
rats put them on my siphily sauce
honey have you been sleeping with
prostitutes and he's just like
no
no
never i've been [ __ ] catch yes
oh my gosh it's like somebody tried to
shoot themselves and failed how did it
take to the 50s to come up with zombies
it'd be like if the
still not as bad as giving uh the throat
cancer like catherine zeta jones did
with uh mike she knew
gilbert godfrey talk about that it's the
funniest thing ever he's like i would
take spina bifida
if i could he just names every disease
i would take steps i would drag my
pecker through a mile of broken glass
just to get downwind of her farts
i don't know if you said that but i
would imagine it's close it's close yeah
it's like i would take stage four
lymphoma if i could just taste
something she wouldn't be able to get me
off of her at a certain point it would
be like a palestinian child throwing
rocks at an israeli tank
he's so fluffy that's why he's so funny
and kids had no idea when they were
watching a lad no clue oh no or problem
child yeah which was somehow rated one
of the worst movies ever and i was like
i don't think so really yeah what they
what they do with cop and a half uh
right behind it
wow i saw that in the theater yeah
they're making the show very different
film aladdin if they just let go like
yeah why don't you ad-lib a little bit
all right
no no no i'd really like to [ __ ] jasmine
stop recording
i can show you my balls cut cut
it's amazing he got away with all that
and then the affleck company was like
hey that one comment about a tsunami was
a dad too much
uh rachel living first female female in
uniform yeah ish get it right gerald it
is
you see what he's doing there alberto
dad he says the ish i tell you blatantly
gay superman he's passive aggressive
he's a [ __ ] no let's not talk that way
we don't allow that language listen i'm
i'm the bee we're all on the same team
we're part of the same alphabet soup
thing right and then it was all but
confirmed when you were having group sex
with an nfl star well that's true you
know she's good for three not four yes
but she she she basically this is like
my country do you know what we call uh
we call them in my country someone like
that what what we call them no but i
don't know what do you call them it's
like
what are you saying a slide
slap slap oh sludge
don't say that you're not allowed to say
that but hold on didn't we we saw your
many many many partners come back they
cut that too from the video right i mean
so yeah he has to answer the question
like i don't know what what what was
that going on he was not many partners i
am here with mario for life it was 20
seconds mario for life that was that was
history fair plus mario's dead he's
still deaf to apartment there was a guy
in leather and chains that came up
behind mario oh do you say tomato
i say
leather ball gag and bad plug you know
okay okay that's not how they explode
this is how the expression goes no mario
no it is well okay just left something
lost in translation not lost in
translation not enough but look look
apparently foursomes you know do
something for you so we've got a side by
side yeah exactly prior to foursomes
because steroids don't exist prior to
foursomes and after force themselves oh
there you go
apparently foursomes gives you yes
yes it's very common to have uh more
abdominals on your ribcage ah yes he has
been eating his vegetables you know
listen i knew that was gonna turn you on
and uh i i mean we should have no no no
no no it's not turning me on i like a
little bit of muscle but not too much if
you're dead do you have to declare that
you have aids um
no no it's not it's not like customs oh
okay
i'm not even going to be on this show am
i
all right
this is very hard
i mean it's hard because you're
distracted yeah it is yes mario okay
i'm sorry i'm sorry he asked the
question with me i wonder what sex
sounds like with men that are just bones
what does it sound like yeah why are you
teeing him up no no no no no it's okay
it's okay it's okay you sound like um
how do you say like um do you know
new orleans yeah you know like louisiana
yeah you sound like a cajun
doing the prayer you know oh with like
the bones
yes
we make good use of the shrunken heck
you know i don't oh no that's disgusting
oh it's that's disgusting mario
saying shut up
why do you have a missing rib i mean did
you just that's it that's not let's not
come on let's not i'll go knock it i
don't i don't watch it i don't want it
i don't want to say another one taken
too soon maybe for mario but not alberto
hey steven your predictions already come
true this is the new york times what
from 2018 actually the abcs of lgbtqia
all the news fit to prince
plus what if you end up in the plus and
you're like oh we don't write a letter
okay can you answer my question though
okay so let me go through
l e for lesbian right grace
we had to go to therapy okay yeah so
then you have b
a g b
a b c
a t t is for let me ask you is it for
transvestite or fourth hundred and two
do you have to do the bottom half no so
it's all of it now okay that's a d b
thank you uh okay q the queue
is the that's the word we're not
supposed to say yeah most of the time
like
queer that's me oh but no you're you're
gay
uh i can be queer too well you can't you
gotta pick oh my god jamaica's are crazy
okay q
and then
q a do you say what's new what's new
york times say hey they signed no next
what the hell does that mean and that's
what does what does that mean
i
actually don't know i think it's actual
[ __ ] yeah well hold on no no no no
no no no no no
hey they tell the guy and they tell the
guy in the teeth to shut his mouth oh
man feed the kids folks you know he
doesn't know anything
so stupid so you're born with both parts
well
yeah i don't think it works like that i
would i mean mario no no you i i don't
and then a is foreign
i think that's asexual and that's mean
huh
like they're not attracted to anyone
that's [ __ ] man
i'm gonna tell you okay okay i'm gonna
tell you and i say this is a guy who is
super gay like i'm really gay super gay
okay
against ireland and i wanted to [ __ ] the
captain the captain yeah does he
the skipper no the skipper too
please touch my balls no no no no no no
i'm there no no that's that's how i felt
no i'm living my truth no you're not so
i'm gonna tell you asexually that's a
guy who cannot get laid who wants a new
name that is you know what he's right
all right
that's a good point berto has a point
okay
[Laughter]
you know what he's a fresh perspective
yeah i appreciate it fresh perspective
yeah i think that's true yeah you have a
fresh perspective
do you know what i'm saying oh no here
we go no question
they're not a sponsor to the show no
they can't do that i have to mention it
doritos
they sponsor you in the app give me my
cooler and scooter
that's not that's the chili sauce
it's the ribs all right okay so first
off watching that clip is not even that
bad no he didn't throw the guy to the
ground and crack him over this they're
supposed to be bang
well i mean
do we have any we would we do it in
mexico de palacia
right the policy if you are walking down
this tree okay
and you see the latin kings do you see a
chapel on one side right and the policy
on the other side
you walk with el chapo hey uncle alberto
can you can you try and move your
mustache like just reorient it because
people on the blaze chat are saying it's
kind of hard to understand you with the
mustache in the way oh people cannot let
me see like that can you hear me better
keep in mind too i'm talking to joe from
the grave well that's true
so it's going to distort a little bit
it's almost like i sound like uh auto
tune you know
let me show you how much of a liar this
man is and of course cnn just took him
at his word
uh watch him here on a local media
report eddie haskell the crap out of it
i just uh take my phone out and i'll
like you know politely ask them like hey
can you just you know
follow the rules like everyone else and
wear a mask the male officer there
basically you know with plain dumb and
pretending you kind of hear what i said
you know he was saying oh i can't hear
you with your mask on
oh yeah that's right
well maybe bi i mean that's a thing
listen
eating
i am gay well yeah but that guy
he's really gay
he's like levels to the do you have like
a game he's so far in the closet he's
finding chapel's tunnels oh geez wow
there we go
again yeah do you prefer around you
do you prefer to reference the dumb
waiter well the point is it's a chapel
stove in the closet okay
yeah this is the issue with john oliver
bending the truth
because the lie is better for him than
the truth that's it and he's also uh
anyway so let's go to the arlington i
wasn't gonna say i'm not gonna so i'm
confusing what i'm allowed to say versus
you know what umberto can't say what i'm
listening and you can get away with it
don't take the risk man let me take for
you okay okay very much you're just
being honest really
you know
that's it let's see people like i tell
people man hey man
if you don't want some if you you don't
want a mexican who tells it like it is
uh-huh walk on down the way walk away
because i tell you like it is you know
right mario know that that's what that's
my key walk to another kill wait
honestly wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hold up
what was that no no no i didn't no i
didn't kill him you but you just said no
no no no no no no no we all heard it
committed suicide we're for the cleaning
things okay
oh
right this gets deep arlington shooting
remember that mr simkin
is involved
in high risk activity
and uh
like second
risk activity
led to the disagreement within the
community high risk
activity
visiting truck stops or i was going to
say i do high risk activity like the
time i went in
the time i went in the porta potty with
george michael oh you don't ever go on
the porta potty with george michael no i
learned my lesson and also the time i
went on the porta potty with boy george
why i don't know why am i finished he's
having sex with guys who have george in
their name first or less than the porta
potty so we're fetish
there's not many of us
that's weird that's gotta be tough to
find a mate yeah uh what would you just
settle down mario so is that no he's
alberto mario is his lover that's what
i'm saying he's settled oh he settled on
mario listen listen
he's better to the
better than waiting around all life for
mr right well it looks he's better to
say
i'm not going to say that mario is going
to win on him beauty pageants no he's
all skin and bone but he's good for he's
not perfect but he's perfect for me
that's right you killed him and now he's
trapped with ah come on not well that's
allegedly it's what
allegedly man allegedly you're like joe
biden i tell you i told you i was not
alleged okay what's that is that cool
ranch doritos are delicious stop it come
on stop it shameless with the plugs okay
listen listen hey zero morgan what what
no i'm super for the previews okay
look at this
hey father black he thinks he's daniel
de lewis over here
he's a guy in a mustache
okay okay okay okay you're not crazy
you're clucking thank you
look if i can like okay oh it's sexy oh
sorry okay yeah sorry i hurt your
feelings well i mean
i
if you're going to commit murder
at least put a mask on to protect those
around you
that's self-explanatory i uh whenever i
whenever i rub a bank or commit murder
you know i wear a mask do you ask your
partner it's not the same to wear a mask
uh that's actually that's actually a
good question it is that's a good
question then listen i don't i don't
when i when i rob banks
whenever i don't bring mario
he's not good with a gun he's kind of a
little [ __ ] well you know he gets
scared he's like when i do
he's like the italian job you know
but he's mexican job well i i was to be
clear not talking about a robbery i i
meant more intimate i don't know yet
that no oh yeah me and mario have sex
after i rub the bang i mean do you put a
penis mask on no no no no no no no but
after i kill the people i rub the bank
mario and i we have sex it's a good time
all right okay the the worst part of
this is the school board covered it up
right so we had the father going to the
school board and hey crocheted you're
stupid i'm not stupid why would you just
say hurtful the worst part what'd you
just say i said the worst part of
other than the rape obviously
i don't know
the worst part is not being covered up
it's not right man hold on you'll
understand do you think if you're being
raped by like i don't know me and mario
you're being raped against your will
that's happening and then after they
sweep it under the rug you're gonna be
like this isn't the word this is the
worst part i don't know man
you won't walk right for a week the boy
actually identifies as gender fluid oh
so that's why he's a boy in a skirt
which one is that which letter
that's a good question oh what is it
which one isn't that
it might be like the alternate cue
because it's very hold on i thought it
was uh lgbtq
btq
now that we have to add the f so it's
lgbt let me make sure i have this right
because listen i'm just a gay guy in a
pancho okay so you know like i'm not an
i'm not a marginalized crest as much
anymore i don't know just gay guy
basically pumpkin spines
so
l lesbian
okay let's be gay
right a is for asexual
uh-huh i there's a lie that's probably a
lie intersex is the person who was born
with both that's my fantasy okay and now
f for gender fluid or for me if for [ __ ]
you this don't make sense you stupid
white people oh hello that makes sense
it's a cultural
it's a cultural difference alberto just
alberto no it's not cultural it's uh
it's more of a iq difference no really i
know a guy is a guy listening a guy a
man can be a man i want to have sex with
men okay but a man cannot be a woman and
then we also want to have sex with women
or men i don't know the rules i don't
know i don't know i'm not going to talk
anymore well 14 years old yeah i know
it's just it's absolutely hard to break
kids in public schools no no listen dave
you said you weren't going to talk i had
to wipe my i had a nose hair here all
right so i was wiping okay i'm about to
say something there in alberto listen
okay even in mexico we're smart enough
to know
listen with with straight people uh-huh
no means no
right right yeah no
with gay people like me and mario no
someone said no no no no
it means something all right well but
how many no's do you have to say for it
to actually mean no that's actually a
good question you know
it's not a hard and fast rule
okay
i do what i want you know well that
doesn't sound that like all i know is i
leave with a smile on my face and my
bag of courage doritos
oh god he keeps plugging it we walk into
it every time too all right so look we
are going to go uh to rumble but we have
to announce the winner of the costume
yeah do we have this really quickly do
you want to announce the winner there
alberto uh and mario do you want to
announce the now what do you do i mean
we announcing the winner is
whenever we do a costume the wiener
people are going to send in their
costume yeah yeah
yeah do we have a costume okay okay yeah
that sounds like fun we'll uh we'll look
at all the crazy white people
yeah dressing up and stupid things you
do you know hold on alberto it's this
this is not like the uh folsom street
fair costume kind of stuff so you it's a
little different hey hey
well i mean that's uncalled for i'm a
family friendly gay i just wanted to be
what i do in the middle of the streets
in san francisco
is my business stay out of my middle of
the street well that's kind of called my
middle of this three my choice um
i don't think that's how it works okay
who's weaning that uh the uh the f
japanese guy
i've got a lot of good ones by the way
that guy's not half japanese no it's
there's
i mean we agree there he's a liar
well okay go all right we got a lot of
good ones but the winner is the winner
is
oh
hey
i'm not even straight
but
that's nice comrades
though elizabeth mario's into it is that
a woman
that's not a guy mario's pissed i just
want to make sure because i don't
understand the rules
i don't know the rules that is a woman
excuse me it's ma'am okay well she's
very beautiful
you know maybe it's time for me to be my
can you show me just a couple more of
the costumes that's the winner that's
the winner and she's going to get a bang
of cool ranch doritos no she's no
yes yes yes yes no
i thought you said only why people could
apply that guy
oh that's that's he's disqualified we
never said that he's disqualified oh
geez oh that's more like me with the
leather mask oh jeez i get it no i get
it okay that's enough of this you know
we should do we should go back to
detroit and we should do some
side-by-sides and see how much worse
it's gotten no no no dang it
i'm never going back
we'll send somebody else that'll
hopefully make it listen i'm from mexico
city yeah and detroit scares me man
would you but it's bad you've got
questions we have like 401ks for
kidnapping right you couldn't pay me to
go to detroit because it's like mexico
city but cold
if he's in mexico city
is it the cold really that that's the
problem it's not the car he's more so
the murder the crack
it's not a nice place you know
that's that's strange you would rather
go with ms listen listen the point is
all all places all countries have a city
they make fun of you know i'm just
having fun like in
the united states do have detroit or in
mexico we have detroit
first off thank you alberto and mario
i'm the creative crane okay
yeah well
join mug club
you know what i like to join
mug club
you do you do that
do you do that stephen
do you want to join mug club
oh he's got the head thing going
i'm gonna get hit because of that call
call the doctor
oh no
oh no
oh there it is